democrats want us to believe
that they're just after that congress
lady
or they're just after trump or they're
just after i don't know there's always
someone they seem to be just after just
one more person and then they'll respect
us then they'll like us right
bill maher who is occasionally honest
often wrong but occasionally honest has
admitted
this isn't about trump or
marjorie greene or cuanon or conspiracy
theories it's about all of us it's about
conservatives it's about christians
it's about people who hold traditional
beliefs in this country
the left thinks we're all the same the
left thinks there's no difference
i've mentioned this on the show you
notice how they don't say alt-right
anymore
the alt-right whatever that at one point
i think it did have a real meaning but
now it doesn't really have any meaning
at all
they don't care about the alt-right or
they're this right or the conservatives
or they just think we're all the same
bill maher
they just think we're all the same and
they think we're all completely
in lunatics or right completely insane
and they
they want us ostracized from society as
long as we're going to
go to the trouble of another impeachment
trial we might as well be honest about
what it's really about
the events of january 6th were a
faith-based initiative
and trumpism is a christian nationalist
movement that believes trump was
literally sent from heaven to save them
it's right there in senator tommy
tuberville's campaign ad
god sent us donald trump because god
knew we were in trouble
a lot of talk now in liberal quarters
about how republicans should tell their
base who still believe the election was
rigged
that they need to grow up and move on
and stop asking the rest of us to
respect their mass delusion
and of course it is a mass delusion but
the inconvenient truth here is that if
you record religious faith
the kind of exalted respect we do here
in america
you've already lost the argument that
mass delusion is bad
it's fun to laugh at q anon with the
baby eating lizard people and the
pedophile pizza parlors but
have you ever read the book of
revelations
uh because bill maher probably hasn't
read the book of revelations because
the book of revelation is not called the
book of revelations the dude couldn't
even get the name of the book right
as he's making fun of it which is true
of so many of these sophomoric
atheist types i mean i think i think the
days of
the bill maher style atheism are over
there was this kind of publishing
fad in the mid-2000s they called him the
new atheists it was like christopher
hitchens
daniel dennett richard dawkins sam
harris and their books i read some of
their books
uh they were very weak and they didn't
even make the arguments they were
purporting to make
but you know it was popular among like
14 year old boys
in urban areas or something and it
wasn't
to be really taken seriously and bill
maher is not to be taken seriously right
he doesn't
he he exposes the biblical literacy and
theological
insight of most of these people he
doesn't even know the name of the book
but he is espousing the view i think of
many leftists namely if you
believe that there is something more to
this world than just physical matter
that uh you know beyond the the tumbler
and the desk and the microphone and my
body if you believe that
our in our bodies we're not just meat
puppets but we actually have
souls or we have mind we have
loves dreams there are ideas there's
mathematics right things that are
metaphysical they're not just physical
that you're kind of kooky now of course
if you put it in those terms to them
they would say no i don't deny math i
don't deny dreams i don't deny ideas but
they
they do they just aren't philosophically
sophisticated enough to
talk about it you know you sort of you
can imagine thomas aquinas looking down
from heaven now saying oh darn i got
owned by bill maher
i never re i never realized that it's
foolish
to believe in the book of revelations
darn totally owned by that
hack comedian i thomas aquinas one of
the
most brilliant people to ever walk the
earth this is what they believe now
you heard that phrase in there that bill
maher mentioned christian nationalism
what is christian nationalism what does
that mean it's a phrase that's become
popular
these these slogans spread like memes
and the left
has been pushing this one recently i
guess christian nationalism means
the belief that we are a nation and a
christian nation at that
which is obviously true
the united states is a christian nation
there is some complexity to that because
it's a christian nation that has broad
toleration among the protestant
denominations and even had toleration
for catholics
and even from the founding era i had
toleration for jews
and didn't totally love muslims because
obviously the early americans were being
uh
kidnapped and killed by barbary pirates
that was our first war after we had
gained independence so that complicated
things but you know generally then we
kind of expanded tolerance
to some muslims too and okay so it's
it's all of that is
complex history is much more complex
than slogans
but while all of that is true it is also
the case that we are a christian nation
we were founded by
christian zealots who who took a ship
over here from england called the
mayflower
and founded a puritanical colony
later puritans who arrived referred to
this as a shining city upon a hill
we had established churches in this
country
well past the founding era our our
document
our founding document the declaration of
independence refers
to the philosophical basis of this
country as the natural rights that
we are endowed with by our creator what
was their vision of a creator well go
back and read their writings
their vision of a creator was at least
broadly speaking
a christian god well of course they were
steeped in the christian culture
it's not it's not a hindu country it's
not a muslim country
it wasn't a jewish country and it wasn't
a
a pagan country right it wasn't a
secular atheist country which i guess
you'd say now the dominant religion in
the country is secular
liberalism or you know sort of atheism i
guess
or some kind of weird paganism with all
the crystals and the horoscopes and all
the wacky stuff that liberals believe
now
but certainly thomas even thomas
jefferson was pretty radical didn't
believe
that john adams didn't believe that
george washington didn't believe that so
what what bill moore is saying is
these awful terrible people they believe
in the vision of america as it existed
from 1620 until like five minutes ago
but that's bad that's evil that's wicked
that needs to be ostracized
because we on the left want to upend
society we want to overturn that
tradition
and implement our radical designs if you
enjoyed that video be sure to hit the
subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you